alright alright alright I'll talk about
the Ronnie classic Doctor Who time and
as selected by my patrons I will be
talking about time and the Rani so this
I mean the timing worked out pretty well
because when I talked about characters
from the classic series that have not
been brought into new who who I think
should I made a point of saying the Rani
was not on that list which prompted
several people ask why not well this
will give me an opportunity to say why
not but before we get into her
specifically let's talk the broad
strokes of this story I'll try to avoid
spoilers but probably I'll probably talk
them eventually but I'll be avoiding
them for now at least so this is the
first outing of the seventh doctor
Sylvester McCoy
this is his inaugural adventure so it's
him the companion of the time was Mel
this is the first time I've encountered
her and then of course we have Kate
Amara as the Rani this is the Rani
second appearance in the show as well
also her last I believe so
what we have is things kick off we don't
really get a proper regeneration on this
they kind of couldn't because Colin
Baker didn't come back to just be killed
off in the opening scene and I can't
really say I blame him for that he
really got shafted and in this whole
experience when when he you know when he
was on the TV show I'm really glad he
got redemption on the audios but what so
what happens it opens with the TARDIS
just kind of getting knocked around and
who we only see The Sixth Doctor from
behind because it's Sylvester McCoy and
a blonde
Wiig and they flip him over and he
basically regenerates right there and
now we have Sylvester McCoy so we're
coming into this with hit it being his
first time and he actually works
surprisingly well for his first outing
and that was interesting for me because
I generally like later Sylvester McCoy
more than I like early Sylvester McCoy
because they kind of I think they were
very much initially trying to counteract
the harshness of Colin Baker's doctor
with someone a little more goofy silly
and and Sylvester McCoy at this point is
kind of doing that but it's working for
me I think there's just an energy and a
charm just performance even at this
point doing the version of the Seventh
Doctor Who I like less but well I also
maybe part of it is maybe part of the
reason I'm more accepting of it in this
sistas is I kind of give up not a total
free pass but like I give a longer leash
to the to the first story of any given
doctor because post regeneration
wackiness they're allowed to be a little
weird or in the case of Tom Baker just
weirder then then they might play it
later so maybe that's part of why it's
working for me here but I like his I
like how rapidly he's talking and he's
bouncing off of everybody I kind of like
his frequent misquoting 'he's of things
and his mix and matching of metaphors
and popular sayings I actually rather
enjoyed that it I'm not it's not
somebody I needed to keep seeing past
this episode but for the purposes of
this especially know he's coming out for
regeneration it really it made sense to
me and I kind of enjoyed that I
mentioned Mel this is my first outing
with Mel and I don't really know if I
can judge her as a character at all
because the only overriding memory
of her is that she screams a lot in this
and first of all she's got a real
unpleasant scream I mean and that's a
weird criticism screams aren't supposed
to be pleasant and this wouldn't even be
a problem if she wasn't screaming so
much holy God so and and she looks
ridiculous I mean it's the 80s so yeah
she looks ridiculous the Ronnie looks
ridiculous too but but we'll get to her
so she she just doesn't work I did I get
very little from her as a character and
she really doesn't work functioning so
she essentially has no function in the
story and she does nothing except get
captured almost get captured get
captured scream scream scream scream she
is she contributes nothing to the plot
of this thing
there was actually a surprisingly high
production value on this a lot higher
than I was expecting the last episode I
saw that was anywhere near this era was
was I think the twin dilemma and the
production design on that when the
production value was real low so I was I
was quite surprised there's there's some
cool sets the Ronnie's lab is kind of
typical but it's fine there's sort of
this leisure I think they called the
leisure palace I forget exactly what
they call it but it's actually a really
cool design and it sits suitably kind of
alien like boy that this place looks a
little weird so that's a really cool set
the makeup for the lovely basically so I
kind of I kind of wandered off the plot
so where they end up where the doctor
Mel end up the Ronnie is running
experiments with what is called strange
matter
I looked it up that is a real thing and
I'm really glad while watching it was
like I'm gonna look it up and hope
that's real because if that's what they
think they can get away with calling
stuff boy please be real so so I know
that there's an excuse for it and it is
strange matter is a real thing but
she'sshe's conducting experiments
there's this strange matter asteroid and
the Ronnie's whole deal if you haven't
seen this and don't know who she is is
that she is a rogue Time Lord a bit like
the master but her whole thing is she is
always in pursuit of these scientific
advancements of running experiments with
absolutely zero morals so she has no
kale as far as even finding out what the
collateral damage of any given
experiment she's trying to run is she
just doesn't care and I know that sounds
cool and we'll come back to I'll talk
about my problems with her but that sort
of baited her basic thing and there are
kind of two races on this planet there
there is a very humanoid race with you
know kind of maybe little scales around
here which is it's not it's not an
amazing design but it gets the job done
plus they put him in these hats with
these really cool hair things going on
so that that only a fairly small amount
of their face is showing that helps sort
of plaster over you know the limitations
of makeup so they're enslaved and
basically well they're enslaved in a
weird way she has their leader in her
lap basically as her primary assistant
and the rest of them basically under
threat of retribution if he if the
leader doesn't go along with her so that
guy is actually a really fascinating
character as you can tell he's going
through a struggle of trying to find the
balance of I know that what I am doing
for the Rani is a bad thing I am helping
her do a bad thing but what she will do
to my people is way way way WAY worse or
at least I believe that
we'll be so watching that struggle and
the way in which he kind of tries to
thread that needle like telling the
doctor look you run away I'm not gonna
try and stop you but I am still gonna
continue to help her because I need to
so as I I thought there was a surprising
amount of depth in his character but the
other race that's on here is a race we
just flat out minions for the Ronnie
they're not being coerced so far as we
know they're just they're just serving
her and they're sort of these weird
four-eyed bad things now normally we you
say multiple lies you think multiple
eyes on the face no they've got two eyes
here two eyes here and one in the back
of their head and honestly the design is
pretty cool and I also like how we kind
of they tried to visualize what it looks
like for them the fact that they're
getting sensory information from four
different directions and that was pretty
cool the the mouth movement on these
things was not great too sometimes it
really didn't move in time with the with
the speech that these things were saying
at all
even when it did it's just a jaw on a
hinge so it's just opening and closing
you know there's no articulation
anywhere there's no animatronics at play
so and they were smart to not show it
right off I think it wasn't until the
second episode there's four in this
story that I don't think it was until
the second episode that they actually
showed it and that was that was probably
for the best but again the limitations
are in the realization of the design the
design itself is kind of a neat idea and
when it doesn't have to move and try and
look like it's talking the execution of
the outfit is not that bad either
pretty good even in places so you've got
them they are aside from a cool look
they don't really have a lot going on to
kind of just your generic minion race
more or less
so let's alright let's let's get to the
Ronnie here's the here's the things that
don't work about the Ronnie in general
and in this story in particular her
introductory story she was very much
sort of set up to be the successor to
the master and and at least for me that
sort of puts her in bad standing already
now I'm not saying the master didn't
kind of need to be rehabilitated he did
he suffer from the problem basically any
villain for a long-running show who is
never permitted to win has which is that
you know no matter how dastardly his
scheme is if he just loses every single
time he shows up he becomes harder to
take as a threat it's the reason that
you know Cobra Commander and Skeletor
event and shredder eventually seem to be
used more for comedy than trying to
actually be intimidated by them because
you've just watched them get to feed it
and you over and over and over and over
again you can't take him seriously
anymore and the master was starting to
suffer from that for to to a certain
extent but rather than try and actually
resuscitate the the reputation of the
master they decided to introduce a
different rogue Time Lord and that's
where we get the Ronnie so in this story
okay so first of all she gets a hold of
the doctor finds out that he is just
regenerated and she induces a bit of
amnesia with the goal of convincing him
to work on her experiments and basically
help come up with the formula she needs
to do sort of the big thing that she's
trying to do but it's not enough for her
to induce amnesia and then be like I'm
your friend
come help me no she has to actually
dress up like Mel which is
I'm sorry it's kind of dumb and I find
myself thinking very early on you know
you're planning the things you're having
to convince him to do are already really
stretching credibility I don't think
you're gaining a lot of stable ground by
looking like Mel I think it would have
made little to no difference and you
look ridiculous so there's that oh I
skipped over this there was one other
thing I wanted to highlight with the
effects that I actually thought was
really cool there's these booby traps in
the quarry because of course there's
always a quarry in these things so
they're these booby traps of these
tripwires that when characters activate
them they basically get trapped in this
forest bubble that flies off and smacks
into something and explodes and the
effect is surprisingly pretty good and
really well-timed in terms of like
appearing to bounce and then you know
dirt shoots up and everything's
obviously they just rigged you know like
a small little cannon with just a throw
throw the dirt around but it's all timed
and integrated really well I was I was
actually pretty impressed by this effect
all things considered so that was neat
but anyway so the rani is convincing the
doctor of stuff that is is way beyond
just yeah it this whole trying to pass
for a mental thing I might have bought
more if her goal was much more
simplified it was just I just need him
to invite me back to the TARDIS I don't
even need him to buy this for very long
I just need him to buy it for long
enough to let me in if it had been
something like that I could have rolled
with it but it's not instead she's going
through these really elaborate motions
to get him to lend his brain power to
her project which has coincidentally
also involved her kidnapping the
greatest minds from history to hook them
into this machine a plot point that adds
absolutely nothing and goes absolutely
nowhere so you've got all that and
impersonating Mel she looks ridiculous
and
okay here's the thing with the Ronnie on
paper I dig her concept especially the
idea of someone who is so into
experimenting that they don't have a lot
of room for scruples or any room for
scruples so it's like they took the
scientist inventor aspect of Davros and
stuck it in the master but it's a woman
and I think part of it comes down to the
performance her performance is I
couldn't decide if it was inconsistent
or just ill-advised because she'll go
from you know obsessing over her work to
being emotional in ways that don't make
sense for the character as I understand
her and I'm not saying she can't get
emotional I know she's not like a robot
or something but she immediately you
know mocks the doctor for being a
sentimentalist and and you would think
someone who was all just about the
science would kind of have a cold thing
going but she gets heated she gets
heated easily like she's always looking
for an excuse to insult her her henchmen
and her minions and the the attitude
there was an incongruity between the
character on paper and the way the
character is played because I'm paper
the character should be and the doctor
he kind of says something to this effect
like somewhat noble but like always
pursuing these dangerous experiments
that can cause a lot of damage but she
doesn't come across I could dedicate a
scientist she comes across like she
comes across like a jock who who wants
to beat up the Nerds and make them do
her homework she's just got this
permanent inferiority complex fueled
anger or at least that's how I read it
and it makes her very uninteresting
because again the core concept of the
character is interesting but the way in
which she's actually executed just is
not and Kate Amara can't do the shifts
in character from sort of smirking I
think I'm winning to anger to smugness
to anger
- do you know just being very
manipulative of people around her -
anger she gets angry a lot I think I'm
kind of saying which again is something
that doesn't seem to fit with what the
main idea of what the character is
supposed to be is you know I don't think
I'm gonna get into spoilers really at
all because the stuff that happens at
the tail end doesn't really need to be
singled out the overall plot is OK it's
functional I don't I'm still not
entirely sure oh you know what
I almost said I'm not entirely sure why
the Rani's even running this particular
experiment but then I remember what goes
on in the last episode because I did not
even binge all the way through it I did
three and then got to the fourth one a
little bit later so I didn't quite make
the connection but here's here's the
other thing and this is finally what
really broke me and like this character
just doesn't work is that you know her
whole premise is being about the
experiments and damn the costs damn the
costs and suffering in life whatever she
doesn't care and yet she expresses that
her goal is to enable something that
where she will be able to rule the
universe like that's that's the Masters
schtick you're now you're now literally
muscling in on his turf and again this
sort of naked grab for power is at odds
with the I just want to run my
experiments but I don't care who gets
hurt by my doing the thing that she is
again largely on paper and I suppose if
I were to be fair and like look back in
my video you know when I said I was
gonna put her on the list of characters
who should be brought back I still don't
think she should be but there are
probably ways that you could write her
and have it work better if you really
drill down to what the original concept
was and work with that because whatever
we ended up with in the eighties just it
just didn't work
so this whole story overall is a very
mixed bag Sylvester McCoy himself is has
slid into this part pretty effortlessly
Mel is really annoying the production
value is surprisingly good especially
for the time period the villain is
generic in most ways you know as soon as
something doesn't go her way she starts
bellowing orders and and and the I feel
like the payoff with the bat monsters
was kind of dumb and weird as well
because I was expecting because there
was a moment where one of them is trying
to convince the ronnied uh basically
hook herself up to the machine she has
all the other geniuses hooked up to to
contribute her own intellect and the
thing was this guy had been so sick of
fant ik that I was like there's got to
be more going on there but it turns out
it was giving the story too much credit
because there really isn't but I it felt
like the story set up this guy secretly
trying to undermine the Rani the whole
time and her not realizing it but it
never pays that off so yeah that's
another thing that that doesn't work the
Rani yourself doesn't really work the
overall plot is just fine
so basically we're left with better than
expected production values for the era
and Sylvester McCoy and I guess the
question is is that enough to carry you
through if it is you know go ahead and
check out check it out if it isn't this
is not one of the ones I would recommend
to to newcomers to the show or to new
who fans who are looking for you know
like a viewing order of stuff to be seen
from the classic era no no I think this
one
well not awful certainly far from the
worst I've seen it's still not great so
those are my thoughts on time and the
Rani what are yours whatever they are
drop something down the comments
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do such as like and subscribe and
support me on patreon I listen to my
blog guys to follow me on Twitter and
maybe do other things as well I forgot
all the stuff that's down in the
description but it is down there
so drop a comment and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]